[Musica]
vorrei iniziare con una domanda semplice
semplice
quanti di voi in questa sala
stamattina appena svegli hanno
controllato il cellulare alzate le mani
non sa di tini e tanto lo so me lo fate
bene cento per cento della sala non male
quanti lo hanno controllato come ultima
cosa prima andare a dormire ieri sera
sulle mani 99 per cento non male
curiosità quanti lo hanno controllato
durante la notte a questo punto eccolo
c'è sempre c'è sempre un sony nambu lo
vi siete mai chiesti come mai
controlliamo il nostro smartphone così
spesso secondo una recente ricerca lo
controlliamo in media 76 volte al giorno
76 volte al giorno cos'è che rende il
nostro cellulare così irresistibile
tanto da controllarlo a letto perché
andiamo a dormire o che ci svegliamo
andiamo a scoprirlo negli anni settanta
michael gilera un ricercatore della
emory university di atlanta ha condotto
un interessante esperimento con dei
piccioni ha preso questi poveri volatili
li ha messi in una gabbia e all'interno
questa gabbia messo un pulsante
dopodiché atti stato due scenari nel
primo scenario ogni qualvolta i piccioni
premevano il pulsante venivano premiati
con del cibo nel secondo scenario invece
è quando i piccioni premevano il
pulsante venivano premiati solo nel 50 o
nel 70 per cento dei casi
secondo voi in quale dei due scenari i
piccioni hanno iniziato a premere questo
pulsante come se non ci fosse un domani
avviso di fatti un'idea ok
beh negli studi di zieler è emerso un
comportamento alquanto peculiare
interessante dei piccioni
un comportamento che è proprio anche di
noi esseri umani
in pratica quando ripetiamo un'azione e
abbiamo la certezza che otterremo un
premio tendiamo a ripetere questa azione
con regolarità ma di intervalli di tempo
piuttosto lunghi al contrario quando
ripetiamo un'azione e il premio ogni
tanto arriva ogni tanto non arriva
iniziamo ad agire in maniera compulsiva
questo perché quando il premio è
imprevedibile quindi non possiamo
prevederlo
ogni volta che il premio arriva beh a
quel punto abbiamo un rush di dopamina
l'ormone del piacere che è molto più
grande rispetto al rush di dopamina che
abbiamo quando il premio invece
prevedibile
in altre parole questo significa che
quando il premio è imprevedibile non lo
possiamo prevedere questo genera
dipendenza
non è un caso che questo meccanismo
psicologico sia ampiamente utilizzato
sfruttato e conosciuto da due industrie
molto floride l'industria del gioco e
l'industria tecnologica
ecco non mi sembra di vedere qui in sala
delle persone con delle slot machine in
tasca o dei tavoli da black jack però
scommetto che tutti tecnici compresi
avete in tasca o nella borsetta uno di
questi lo smartphone rappresenta oggi lo
stesso pulsante l'equivalente di quel
pulsante su cui i piccioni premevano il
loro becco e di fatto è un po la slot
machine dell'industria tecnologica
se lo controlliamo al mattino appena
svegli
se lo controlliamo la sera prima andare
a dormire e decine di altre volte
durante il giorno è perché questa come
potremmo definirla mattonella
elettronica e le app che ci sono dentro
soprattutto i social media sono pieni
zeppi di questi meccanismi a premio
imprevedibile meccanismi e preve
imprevedibile che generano dipendenza
vediamo un esempio il pulsante mi piace
è stato introdotto da facebook
nel 2008 se poi diffuso a macchia d'olio
in molti altri siti
il pulsante mi piace è un ottimo esempio
il meccanismo a premi imprevedibile che
genera dipendenza
ogni volta che postiamo un nuovo
contenuto infatti non sappiamo quanto
successo avrà non sappiamo quanti mi
piace otterrà ci ritroviamo quindi nella
stessa identica situazione di quei
piccioni che premevano il pulsante non
sapevano se avrebbero ottenuto il premio
oppure no il cibo oppure no
noi premiamo il pulsante pubblica e non
sappiamo se avremo l'approvazione degli
altri oppure no
ogni post sui social media quindi sui
social network è un po una scommessa ad
alto rischio se i mi piace le
visualizzazioni cuoricini arriveranno
beh ma andrà molto bene significa che
avremo quel rush di dopamina che di
fatto ci renderà sempre più dipendenti
da questi servizi
se invece non dovessero arrivare beh la
nostra autostima ne potrebbe un po
risentire
eppure la funzione mi piace è solo uno
dei tanti esempi di meccanismi a premio
imprevedibile che sono dentro la nostra
mattonella elettronica
dovete infatti sapere che nella silicon
valley
esistono interi team di ingegneri il cui
unico scopo è quello di progettare
sviluppare e perfezionare delle
funzionalità che vadano a sfruttare le
nostre vulnerabilità psicologiche e ci
tengono incollati a questi schermi
questo perché è più tempo trascorriamo
incollate a questi schermi più
pubblicità possono vendere quindi
maggiori sono il loro fatturato
dite che sto un po esagerando prova a
fare un indovinello
secondo voi chi ha pronunciato queste
parole il sito è stato progettato per
sfruttare le vulnerabilità umane il
ragionamento alla base dello sviluppo di
determinate funzioni è stato il seguente
in che modo possiamo consumare quanto
più tempo ed attenzione possibili dei
nostri utenti
vi do tre opzioni iniziamo alla prima è
stato maurizio crozza mentre imita mauro
corona b è stato un ricercatore di
qualche università sconosciuta in cerca
di facile pubblicità c il primo
presidente di facebook è ormai velo
sfilato l'indizio che vi volevo dare che
non è stato maurizio crozza a dire
questa frase queste parole e anche
abbastanza pesanti è stato il primo
presidente di facebook sean parker sean
parker tra l'altro non è l'unico
dissidente non è l'unico della silicon
valley che sta pronunciando parole di
fuoco su queste tattiche utilizzate
dalle aziende del tech per andare a
condizionare per creare dipendenza nei
propri utenti sempre più spesso stanno
emergendo interviste di ex dirigenti
della silicon valley che di fatto si
sentono pentiti del lavoro che hanno
fatto negli ultimi 5 10 anni
il problema è che questi dirigenti i
pentiti non sembrano avere una soluzione
intervistato da una giornalista uno di
questi dirigenti di facebook tra l'altro
uno molto importante
il nome impronunciabile quindi non mi
chiede di pronunciarlo ha detto
testualmente io purtroppo non ho una
soluzione è la mia unica soluzione non
usare questi strumenti ai miei figli non
è permesso utilizzare quella ci siamo
capiti ecco noi non siamo degli ex
dirigenti della silicon valley
multimilionari ciechi sociale lo
smartphone nelle altre app le utilizza
per lavoro
io stesso lo faccio c'è chi
semplicemente non vuole rinunciare al
piacere della nuova tecnologia o di
rimanere in contatto con i propri
contatti sociali e con i propri amici
se le persone che questo problema lo
hanno causato non sembrano avere una
assoluzione
come possiamo difenderci da questi
meccanismi a premi imprevedibile che ci
rendono dipendenti
come possiamo evitare di trasformarsi in
dei piccioni addestrati negli ultimi
dieci anni e ho condiviso con i lettori
del mio blog
decine sono addirittura centinaia di
strategie pratiche concrete proprio per
riprendere il controllo e il nostro
tempo tra l'altro da ex giudica un
debole per le arti marziali
quindi oggi vi vorrei parlare di
tecniche di difesa personale digitale
ovvero dei semplici stratagemmi per
andare a contrastare questi meccanismi a
premi imprevedibile che ci rendono
dipendenti ne vedremo 3 iniziamo dalla
prima che è quella un po più semplice ed
immediata insomma una tecnica che
potrete mettere in pratica da subito ho
appena terminato questo top non durante
grazie uno dei meccanismi più subdoli
utilizzati dalle aziende tecnologiche le
aziende del tech per incollarci i nostri
schermi è quello di sfruttare i colori
sgargianti
per andare ad eccitare la nostra vista
ai nostri occhi ci ritroviamo così con
icone giallo fluo notifiche rosso fuoco
e schermi da zilioni di colori
la parola d'ordine è quella di consumare
l'attenzione del consumatore andando a
conquistarne gli occhi
fortunatamente tristan harris un ex
ingegnere di google uno di quelli che
lavorava proprio in quei team che
progettano funzionalità acchiappa
attenzione ci suggerisce una strategia
tanto semplice quanto efficace per
andare a contrastare questo effetto
albero di natale del nostro telefonino
quale ci suggerisce tristan harris è di
utilizzare il nostro telefonino in
modalità bianco e nero
si tratta una funzione nascosta un po
tra i meandri le impostazioni al nostro
cellulare
se però cercate su google ironia della
sorte le parole android in bianco e nero
oppure iphone e in bianco e nero
troverete queste impostazioni e potrete
quindi attivarlo parliamoci chiaro
utilizzare il cellulare in bianco e nero
è un po strano non è da tutti io l'ho
fatto per un certo periodo
ripeto è strano se però in questo
periodo vi ritrovate a utilizzare il
vostro telefonino un po troppo spesso un
po troppo frequentemente provate
attivare questa funzione
vedete cosa succede una cosa molto molto
interessante bene passiamo alla tecnica
numero due la tecnica e difesa personale
digitale numero due
questa probabilmente la conoscete già
però sono abbastanza sicuro che in pochi
la applicano davvero vediamo se darvi un
punto di vista un po diverso vi aiuterà
a metterla in pratica
naturalmente sto parlando delle
notifiche push ovvero quei messaggini
quei alert che riceviamo continuamente
durante il giorno whatsapp facebook e
mail la seconda tecnica di difesa
personale digitale consiste nell
eliminare completamente le notifiche
push
intendo tutte le notifiche push quindi
social whatsapp soprattutto facebook
eccetera eccetera perché le notifiche
push di fatto sono il classico esempio
di meccanismo a premio imprevedibile che
creano dipendenza
ogni volta che riceviamo una notifica
siamo attratti come api dal miele e
interrompiamo il flusso dei nostri
pensieri al nostro lavoro pur di andar
là a controllare
così facendo di fatto stiamo permettendo
ad un'app ad un collega ad un amico oa
chiunque altro di dettare l'agenda della
nostra giornata eliminare le notifiche
push significa dunque riprende il
controllo e il nostro tempo e
controllare il nostro smartphone solo
nei nostri tempi e siamo così arrivati
alla tecnica di difesa personale
digitale numero 3
questa è una tecnica cintura nera quindi
serve un pochino più di impegno un
pochino più di pratica però se la farete
vostra finalmente inizierete a sfruttare
la tecnologia nonna ad esserne sfruttati
per raccontarvela vi devo raccontare
quello che mi è successo qualche mese fa
a londra
ero nella sala di attesa del dentista a
londra punto eravamo in tre tutti e tre
al cellulare naturalmente anche io lo
ammetto quando me ne sono reso conto
però ho fatto qualcosa che non faceva
diverso tempo ho preso il mio smartphone
me lo sono messo in tasca e
semplicemente mi sono immerso nella noia
nella frustrazione dell'attesa ecco è
stato un po come rinascere
negli ultimi anni
5 10 anni abbiamo sviluppato questa
tendenza a voler riempire qualsiasi
tempo morto della nostra vita e gli
smartphone rappresentano il tappabuchi
ideale è un po come se non fossimo più
in grado di tollerare le emozioni
negative come ad esempio la noia e
appena se ne presenta un ala reprimiamo
tiriamo fuori il nostro schermo magico e
ci mettiamo a guardare qualche app su
carlo zucchi a tempo così facendo però
abbiamo smesso di ascoltarci abbiamo
smesso di conoscerci persi in questi
feed infiniti e continuiamo a scrollare
alla ricerca dell'ennesima iniezione di
dopamina di fatto non assaporiamo più la
vita
eppure la noia come quelle emozioni
negative che sopprimiamo una precisa
funzione evoluzionistica la natura non
lascia mai nulla al caso
la noia serve per ricaricare le nostre
pil e serve per alimentare la nostra
creatività
qualche settimana fa era questo convegno
con thomas friedman che è un premio
pulitzer e colonnista del new york times
e friedman a ha detto una frase
bellissima sulla noia quando premi il
pulsante pausa di uno smartphone questo
si ferma ma quando preme il pulsante
pausa di un essere umano questo si avvia
oggi più che mai abbiamo bisogno di
creare e difendere questi momenti di
vuoto e di rigenerazione perché questi
due momenti ci permettono
fondamentalmente permettono al nostro
corpo e la nostra mente di riflettere
prendere fiato crescere certo non è
facile
se le aziende hi tech hanno investito
tutti questi soldi per condizionarci
non è facile poi abbandonare questi
meccanismi perché comunque ci danno dei
vantaggi
se però vogliamo tornare ad assaporare
la nostra vita se vogliamo riprendere il
controllo della nostra vita dobbiamo
almeno provarci
dobbiamo provare a testare alcune queste
tecniche di difesa personale digitale
certo le occasioni e non ci mancheranno
soprattutto per applicare la terza
quella che riguarda l'immersione nella
noia la prossima volta che sarete in una
sala d'attesa la prossima volta che
sarete in fila o magari tra un tet work
è un altro invece di agire
meccanicamente come dei piccioni
addestrati appena sentirete
quell'impulso che avrete tirar fuori il
cellulare controllare lo schermo
fermatevi un attimo osservate
quell'impulso e deciderete di non
seguirlo immergetevi nella noia
accettatela usate da un po come un
balsamo lenitivo per la vostra mente per
il vostro corpo
iniziate ad osservare l'ambiente che vi
circonda
osservate le persone che vi circondano
potete fare anche adesso perché ben
sapete solo se avremo la forza di
riprendere il controllo del nostro tempo
e della nostra attenzione
potremo riscoprire la nostra umanità in
fondo potremmo anche a riscoprire la
gentilezza che ci circonda grazie
[Applauso]